more a picture of a grandmother than a
head of state as she was dressed in her
usual clothes for balmoral the queen had
still wanted to personally appoint her
15th prime minister despite recent
concerns about her health
i think what we've seen today is what we
would normally see at buckingham palace
the pictures are no more and no less
and
the royal family have always especially
imagined they operate under the
premise of see and be seen so that is
indeed what's happened today the
official work continues you know that's
what the monarchy is about it's about
that continuity keeping up with what the
papers are coming across
queen's desk as our head of state
this was her last official outing in
july before heading to balmoral
since then no photographs have been
published of her on her summer break the
camera's only here now because of the
handover
last weekend she didn't go with prince
charles and camilla to her usual
favorite the braemar games but there are
no suggestions that she is deteriorated
more a sense that we all just need to
get used to the fact she can't quite do
as much anymore the palace are certainly
taking much more of a common sense
approach adapting the queen's plans so
that she can carry out the duties that
she believes are expected of her and in
this case it means starting a very
important relationship with liz trust
her majesty has often described how
prime ministers unburdened themselves
during their weekly audiences and that
may well come as some reassurance to her
new prime minister who has so much in
that entry
inevitably there will be all kinds of
comparisons between the start of one in
2019 and now the beginning of another
what hasn't changed is her determination
to keep working in any way she can even
at ninety six
read on mills sky news at balmoral